here's the kind of the real um
i don't know maybe it's that maybe it's
the heaviest underlying theme is just
the idea and it is it's about happiness
right
not only about happiness but this sort
of underlying
unhappiness in the world underlying
sadness in the world
when i was a kid and i was working at
wendy's and i saw jean and i saw that
she was freaking happy
and i knew
that i wasn't
and i didn't even know if i could be
it didn't seem like an achievable thing
it seemed like there was too much
underlying
things in the world that just are gonna
be bad
right
um
and i always sense that in the world i
always sensed always i always had this
sense in the world of this underlying
sadness underlying despair this
underlying suffering
and i don't want to use the term
depression because maybe you wrap all
those things together because depression
seems like it's a clinical sort of like
a problem that you treat type thing and
i didn't feel like this was a clinical
problem
it just seemed like life to me
was not gonna go the way you wanted it
to go
for anyone
you're gonna end up in the wrong job
you're gonna end up in the wrong
relationship you're gonna something's
gonna be wrong with your health
um something's gonna be wrong in your
family
and we're gonna die
and we're all gonna die and before we
die we're gonna suffer
and by the way everyone that you know
and everyone that you love is gonna
suffer and die
and so i i would always i kind of had
this
underlying sense of the world
and then i would catch like glimpses of
people that were happy and
sometimes it was someone like gene there
was another guy that worked at a
freaking junkyard
who was kind of jacked especially when i
was younger you know when you were
younger
and in the in the 70s
if someone was jacked in the 70s like it
was a whole
it was like a next level right yeah
because you're you're not used to seeing
people that are jacked at all and
i remember seeing this guy who's worked
at a junkyard
and and he looked happy and i was like
dude this guy's just jacked and just
lifting
engine parts around the junkyard
and it seemed like he was happy
so
that's sort of this underlying
theme and i'll tell you like when i got
to the teams thank god
[Music]
when i got to the teams that's when i
started feeling like oh
like kind of happy like this is cool
the people i'm with are kind of cool and
life's not going to be perfect but we're
going to have a good time living this
imperfect life
so i started to get a little bit
relieved of that as i got as i got older
but i think that
you know johnny kind of realizes that
he's not going to be happy
and and this is the other sort of the
other sort of underlying theme
is this idea of of
sacrifice
and
when johnny realizes that he can't be
happy or at least he doesn't think he
can be happy
he sees that
you know kind of the way i looked at
gene the wendy's salad bar girl
but that's his brother
and the situation unfolds where he's not
going to be able to be happy anymore
where where artie is not going to be
happy anymore and
johnny knows if he makes sacrifices he
could preserve the happiness for his
brother
especially because he's never going to
be happy himself
um
you know i had this conversation with
stoner one time we were out surfing
and he was asking me that he's like bro
i don't know it's like the same thing
he's like bro i'm never gonna how how
are you how am i ever gonna be happy i'm
never gonna be happy you know we're
literally it's like a beautiful
southern california we're out at our
surf spot
for whatever reason there's not many
guys out there's a little offshore
breeze the water's warm it's a you know
chest to head high swell pretty
consistent like it's it doesn't get any
better
and he's out here saying to me like i
don't know how do you ever how you ever
find happiness and i'm like bro this is
it man
this is it right here
and that's what
you know that's what that's what
you have to be able to find
you have to be able to find that
the path that you're on
even though it's challenging even though
they're suffering that's that's the
happiness too
and the sacrifice part is putting others
above yourself you know and obviously on
this podcast we talk about heroes and we
talk to heroes in many cases
and most of the ones that we talk to
here are military people right soldiers
sailors airmen marines
but those aren't the only people
those aren't the only people in the
world that are heroes right and and i'm
not just talking about law enforcement
and you know firefighters and first
responders well there's all kinds of
people in the world that put others
above themselves
and put other people's happiness above
themselves
and and whether that's mothers and
fathers
and
sisters and brothers and wives and
husbands and friends i mean there's
friends that do that
that
put
other people's happiness and other
people's success above themselves
and
really that's
that's the underworld that's one of the
other underlying themes of the book
is and then you know that's that's a
theme that's consistent with all the
books that have written fiction
non-fiction people that are putting
others above themselves
that's what leadership is and ultimately
that's what life is about
so
i think if you can put other
others before yourselves
then if we do that then you can find
some happiness and at a minimum at a
minimum
you can leave the world in better
condition than you found it
and if you can pull that off i think if
you can pull that off
then you can die with a clean conscience
and you can die with a smile on your
face
and you can leave a smile on the face of
the people you
left behind
and that's a good life
and that is
final spin